je me présente devant vous à l'âge de 52
ans et pourtant je suis né il ya
seulement quatre ans alors l'équation
peut sembler à prime abord un peu bancal
un peu incohérente
mais je vais vous en développer
l'inconnu qui en fait partie et vous
allez pouvoir constater que son résultat
est très juste
j'ai donc derrière moi 48 années en mode
survie quarante huit années de
souffrance des frustrations qui ont bien
heureusement laissé place à une
existence paisible et heureuse
j'aurais pu me reconstruire par le biais
de la psychothérapie classique mais
c'est sur le chemin de la spiritualité
que j'ai découvert ma délivrance j'ai
trouvé des notions similaires parfois
très identique à la psychologie dit
classique et qui m'ont accompagné durant
de nombreuses années dans une sincère et
profonde introspection ajit jaïn disait
on ne peut résoudre un problème avec le
mode de pensée qui l'a engendré or il me
fallait trouver une formule une équation
une solution qui me permettrait de
comprendre tous ces événements
douloureux qui avait traversé mon
existence afin de pouvoir les accepter
parce que qu'est-ce qui fait mal ce qui
fait mal c'est l'inconnu justement ce
qui fait mal c'est la question restée
sans réponse
ce qui fait mal c'est la résistance face
à des événements qu'on ne peut ni
contrôlées ni maîtrisé
c'est ce qui fait mal aussi c'est cet
état de névrose permanent dans lequel on
se maintient lorsqu'on est persuadé
qu'on n'a pas d'autre choix que de subir
à travers diverses et lectures je verrai
hutin j'ai véritablement réussi à faire
un saut quantique qui m'a permis de voir
les choses sous un autre angle en
physique quantique on nous apprend qu'un
résultat des plans du point de vue de
l'observateur et c'est ainsi que j'ai pu
transformer mon passé
choisir un avenir passer de l'état de
victime à celui de créateur et basculer
d'une position ancré dans un fatalisme
comblant à un état de liberté totale
mais surtout j'ai compris j'ai compris
d'où provenait cette méprise qui m'avait
insidieusement mené jusqu'au chaos dans
lequel j'ai failli à plusieurs reprises
perdre la vie lorsqu'on est en mode
survie
ça fait mal très mal et on n'a qu'une
envie c'est que cela cesse cette
maîtrise ce malentendu
les trois quarts de la population le
fond il n'est pas spécifique un parcours
particulièrement compliqué ou difficile
même si certaines épreuves sont
particulièrement déterminante en ce qui
me concerne pour poser le tableau j'ai
été abandonné à l'âge de deux ans que
j'ai connu leurs fouilles dina jusqu'à
me 5 ans et demi ou là une famille dont
je porte le nom est venu d'adopter alors
une famille avec une lignée prestigieuse
une famille avec des valeurs avec le
sens profond du devoir de la droiture
mais également une famille qui avait la
particularité de penser d'estimer que
l'amour est une faiblesse partant de là
il n'était pas à même de manifester une
quelconque affection et on comprend que
de par mon jeune parcours j'étais une
petite fille très en manque d'affection
très en demande d'amour
alors je servais ce qui se passait
autour de moi et j'étais témoin avec
envie des relations entre les parents et
les camarades de classe à la sortie
d'école
c'était des câlins des les fusions de
tendresse des démonstrations affectives
mais moi je ne connaissais pas tout ça
moi je n'y avaient pas droit
m
je me demandais bien pourquoi et comme
je vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure ce qui
fait mal c'est la question restée sans
réponse
alors cette réponse je suis allé la
chercher
j'ai fait mes propres déductions et j'en
suis arrivé à la conclusion que si ge
energy si je n'y avaient pas droit c'est
que tout simplement je ne le méritais
pas d'ailleurs si j'avais été abandonnée
c'était bien parce que je ne méritais
pas à des trémies mon père mon père
adoptif avait pour habitude de me dire
une phrase un régulièrement qui me
conforter dans ses conclusions il me
disait ah line dans la vie on ne tombera
jamais pour qui tu es mais uniquement
pour ton nom août et boucles blondes
en réponse dans cette phrase je me suis
très vite mariée à l'âge de 18 ans pour
faire disparaître ce nom et durant des
années
je me suis colorer les cheveux et
surtout l'itie ces fameuses boucles afin
de les faire disparaître comme une fuite
désespérée envie d'exorciser cette
terrible sentence
lorsque mon père est décédé j'ai osé
demander à ma mère mais pourquoi ne
m'avez vous jamais manifestés
d'affection ma mère a eu cette réponse
très percutante
elle m'a dit aline nous n'étions pas la
portée mais nous étions là pour éduquer
alors à mon sens l'un et l'autre ne sont
pas incompatibles mais j'ai compris avec
le recul qu un sens exacerbé du devoir
asphyxié la spontanéité de l'élan
lorsqu'on est dans la maîtrise dans le
contrôle les apparences on se coupe
on se sépare de la spontanéité du
mouvement or l'affect et du domaine de
l'impulsivité on ne calcule pas avant de
manifester son affection
c'est une impulsion spontanée
l'amour vous savez est la quête
essentielle de chaque être humain et ce
dès sa naissance il va le chercher à
travers ses premiers repères qui sont
ses parents puis il ya l'extérieur avec
l'image de soi d'une renvoi et c'est là
que la confusion s'installe
c'est là que dans cette quête d'amour
nous y perdons l'essentiel le plus
important nous y perdons nous mêmes
notre identité en effet nous prenons
généralement 3 fausse route
la première c'est que nous nous
identifions à nos émotions lorsque
quelqu'un va nouveau rejeté nous
méprisent et nous insulter notre
première réaction va être l'émotion et
le cerveau d'un enfant n'est pas
suffisamment mature pour savoir gérer
ses émotions
donc il va s'identifier à la blessure
générés par ces mêmes émotions
nous sommes là dans la notion des
blessures de l'enfance il faut savoir
que lorsque des émotions reviennent
régulièrement se répètent elles
finissent par construire par
cristalliser cellulaire mans à
l'intérieur de nous des sentiments
général réducteur
lorsqu'ils sont liées à une blessure ce
sont les sentiments d'abandon
d'injustice d'infériorité on comprend
que lorsqu on s'identifie à autre chose
qu'à nous-mêmes ou s'éloigne de notre
véritable personnalité
pire encore dans ce cas de figure nous
fonçons tout droit dans des stéréotypes
que l'on pourrait classer en trois
profils bien distincts il y a le profil
de la victime
on me fait mal je suis une victime il ya
le profil du bourreau se profile c'est
celui qui à force d'avoir mal on va
commencer à faire mal d'abord en
espérant ne pas avoir mal il ya le
profil du sauveur que je connais très
bien qu'ils mettraient famille et le
profil du sauveur c'est celui qui a
forcé d'avoir mal va estimer qu'il n'a
pas sa place dans la société
alors qu'est ce qu'il va faire il va
chercher une place et va se mettre au
service de l'autre
je dirais même plus aux sacrifices pour
l'autre
la deuxième fausse route
c'est que nous prenons pour vérité
l'interprétation que l'autre se fait de
nous or elle n'est que le reflet de sa
propre intériorité
nous sommes là dans la notion de l'effet
miroir lorsque quelqu'un par exemple on
va nous dire oh mais tu es quelqu'un de
beaucoup trop extravertie nous allons
accueillir ce jugement comme étant une
vérité pire encore une vérité qui
déplaît or dans notre quête d'affection
dans notre quête d'amour on n'a qu'une
envie c'est d'être acceptée de plaire
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va y
répondre
en endossant la panoplie de l'introverti
dans ce cas de figure
un autre exemple si quelqu'un nous dit
oh mais tu es quelqu'un de beaucoup trop
sérieux
hop on va endosser le costume du clown
et c'est ainsi tout un éventail de
panoplie de costumes différents que nous
endossons dans notre existence au gré de
nos rencontres de nos échanges afin de
répondre aux attentes de l'extérieur on
comprend là aussi qu'on s'éloigne de
notre véritable identité
mais pire encore parce que croyant bien
faire
nous sommes en fait dans la manipulation
à partir du moment où on joue un rôle en
vue d'obtenir quelque chose de quelqu'un
même si l'intention derrière et la plus
honorable qui soit en l'occurrence se
faire aimer se faire accepter
il n'en reste pas moins que c'est de la
manipulation c'est faire le choix de la
superficialité au détriment de
l'authenticité la troisième fausse route
c'est que nous déléguons à l'extérieur
la responsabilité de combler notre soif
d'amour personne d'autre que nous mêmes
mais mieux équipés ni placé pour y
répondre de la manière dont nous
l'entendons et qui est propre à chacun
de reprendre mon exemple je désirais
j'attendais de la part de mes parents
des câlins des manifestations affectif
ou verbales mais eux mêmes n'ayant pas
connu cela comment pouvait qu'il me les
transmettre
évidemment qu'ils m'ont aimée mais à
leur façon avec les outils qu'ils
avaient en leur possession et moi
aveugle et de mon côté par mes propres
désirs mes attentes je suis passé
complètement à côté
lorsqu on persévère dans ce genre en
attente ces points dream est
irrémédiablement le risque de la
déception avec son lot de souffrances et
de frustrations dont je vous ai parlé en
début d'intervention
vous savez j'ai accompagné ma mère
jusqu'à son dernier souffle dans
l'espoir d'un gène qui n'est jamais
venue depuis j'ai compris qu'à sa façon
elle me l'avait montré alors la voilà
cette terrible et fameuse inconnue c'est
l'identification à l'image de soi
renvoyé par l'extérieur s'en séparer
c'est renaître avec notre véritable
identité faire un pas vers soi c'est
également se détacher de la croyance que
ce même extérieur doit combler nos
manques
encore faut-il être capable de les
combler soit mène pas évident lorsqu'on
s'est construit sur des sentiments
réducteur tels que je voulais mentionner
tout à l'heure mais c'est pourtant là la
clé de la renaissance c'est devenir
véritablement l'adulte émancipée et
responsable qui n'a plus besoin du
regard ou de la validation extérieur et
donc est à même de transcender ses rêves
en réalité puisqu'il a dépassé les
limites du déterminisme
alors voilà je suis né il ya quatre ans
lorsque je me suis aimé en pardonnant
aux autres de n'avoir pu le faire de la
manière dont je vous l'entendez chaque
attitude est légitime car elle dépend
d'un parcours personnel je me suis
réalisé lorsque j'ai cessé de focaliser
sur mes faiblesses comme avait pu le
faire l'éducation parentale ou scolaire
mais en misant sur ce qu'ils avaient
totalement occulté la télé gensse et le
verbe et du coeur je suis heureuse et ce
bonheur est invulnérable car il ne
dépend que de moi même je suis
consciente que je ne suis pas maître des
événements qui vont se dérouler dans mon
existence
mais je le suis de l'impact que je leur
accorde un avis à ce propos il est
beaucoup plus sage lorsque la tempête
arrive depuis et tel le roseau plutôt
que de résister comme le chêne par caen
l'accalmie revient le réseau tout
doucement se relève
alors que le chien est brisée reste à
terre je ne suis pas éloigné de mes
congénères pour autant maintenant qu'il
ne comble plus un manque
mako conversation m'ont échangé en est
devenu que plus désintéressée
authentique et sincère lorsque mon père
désespéré devant les bulletins scolaires
me disais mais aline que vas-tu donc
faire de ta vie il est vrai que mes
seules notes acceptable était en
philosophie ou en latin je lui répondais
et bien je prendrai la parole
je ferai de la fouille de la philosophie
et je parlerai nous devons les foules et
mon père me répondait aline métier
d'orateur n'existe plus depuis l'époque
des romains
aujourd'hui que fej aujourd'hui je
transmets une philosophie de vie à
travers des conférences et des ateliers
alors osez être vous même
il croyait envoie rêve car il n'y a pas
de fumée sans feu et il ne pourrait
germer sur la présence d'une part de
possibles
[Applaudissements]